yeah they have
the second or third most uh highest
number of explosive and big plays with
any team in the league so it's pretty
obvious
a lot of catch and run plays um
they're very aggressive get the ball
down the field
and they have a variety of things they
do and they create explosive play
opportunities and
they have players that can make them
he always chatty and
i just it bill belichick is the greatest
coach of all time in any sport but i
just can't help but laugh when i see
that absolute no emotion
no inflection
doesn't want to be there clearly has no
desire to interact with anyone
uh in any confine other than a football
field or a film room but that's okay
that's his prerogative when you have
that many pellets on the horses you
would say chris that's right you're
allowed you're allowed to be that way
all right this
thursday's draft like every thursday
during this season biggest match-ups of
the week to come i got the trivia
question to determine the first pick in
the draft chris here we go
washington has started five quarterbacks
since kirk cousins left for minnesota
alex smith
case keenum and colt mccoy are three of
the five who have started for washington
name one
of the other two have started a game
since cousins left oh my gosh this is
like so easy and i'm choking on this
here right now hold on a second it must
not be that easy smith case keenum colt
mccoy who am i missing that started
another game
oh wow um
is there a time limit control room um
[Music]
uh
gosh okay i give up i can't think of one
go ahead i got it wrong damn mark
sanchez and josh johnson man i would
have never got josh johnson i don't know
if i would ever got to mark sanchez
either oh damn it okay go ahead you get
to go first
all right i get to go first on a day
when there's really no obvious number
one i'm gonna start though since we're
only three days removed from
sam darnold seeing ghosts against the
new england patriots on a monday night
now baker mayfield the first pick and
that
yeah hayley joel
mayfield is going to make his way to uh
foxborough to take on the patriots and
if they're able to do it to sam darnold
they're going to do it to baker mayfield
they've done it countless times to first
and second year quarterbacks and
whatever they whip up and it's probably
going to be very different that's what's
going to happen they're going to be
ready cleveland will be to deal with
exactly what the patriots did on monday
night and then they're going to come out
and they're going to do something
completely different and mayfield's not
going to be ready for that and the
browns aren't going to be ready for it
it's going to be the biggest test yet of
his career this is the best defense he's
faced by far
and the browns moving closer and closer
to desperation mode at two and four two
weeks to get ready for this game it does
not matter and it really makes you
wonder how much of what was thrown
at sam darnold on monday night was aimed
at messing with the browns and maybe
setting them up for something they're
not going to see on sunday but that's
the match up baker mayfield versus a
defense
that that could ultimately be remembered
along the lines of the 1985 bears if
they keep doing what they've been doing
yeah i mean uh you're right it's scary i
mean chris chris consider this
one touchdown pass allowed by the
patriots defense so far this year and 18
interceptions no it's it's insane what
they're doing right now i mean it really
is uh they're it's it's a different way
than the 85 bears who just physically
overpowered you this is a little bit
more about
schemes and great coverage and then bill
belichick coaching to confuse you know
people up front and all that so it is
going to be interesting uh i'll say this
and let to echo what bill said this is
the most dangerous offense they've had
to deal with this year to this point too
so that'll be interesting to see
nonetheless but okay good pick by you
i'm not going to argue that very much
all right mine is going to go um to our
sunday night football game
rogers versus spags okay
yeah you pick aaron rodgers in every
draft it could be a draft about
defensive lineman and you'd find a way
to pick aaron rodgers that's totally
false you're erroneous on all claims
there okay erroneous okay but either way
this is gonna steve spagnolo okay first
off mike
um the kansas city chiefs after the
first drive last week when denver went
down and smashed it down their throat
and you went whoa here goes the same old
kansas city bullcrap you know what they
did mike
they blitzed
like mad men for the rest of the game so
maybe they're watching the show maybe
they heard what i said last week because
they changed their approach last week
you know they got away from this slow
death defense so that to me is going to
be a big aspect of this matchup again to
see who wins that because kansas city
did things last week against denver that
they had not done all year i watched
kansas city on film every week they did
different creative coverages they were
more disguises they were a lot more
aggressive blitzing uh by far the most
blitzing i saw this whole year and it's
going to take that type of stuff to
confuse rogers and lefleur if they want
to win especially without a hundred
percent
patrick mahomes or not at patrick
mahomes in general i really look at that
as being one of the big matchups of the
weekend
i can't believe you said roger's in the
floor without saying rogers and the
floor
but you're absolutely right and i don't
know what to make of the chiefs defense
because they achieved at a very high
level last thursday night but they were
playing a ridiculously bad
offense but maybe that's the moment that
they they find a way because they have a
lot of good pieces it's just a matter of
getting them to play together and making
it all work and their biggest test of
the year with aaron rodgers
orchestrating the offense all right i am
going to
um i i got to go with the thursday night
game this one's fairly obvious but
adrian peterson against the minnesota
vikings front seven they know him he
knows them there's a lot of back and
forth between those guys there was
plenty of chatter before the 2017 game
when the saints went to minnesota this
is the the best chance adrian peterson's
probably ever going to have to to show
that that former team
that he still can get it done and maybe
make them regret pushing him onto the
scrap heap a couple of years ago and and
it's all washington really has this is
their best play yes terry mclaren is a
very good rookie receiver but you're not
going to be able to set up the pass if
you can't run the ball and adrian
peterson has shown from time to time he
still has the high end skills that made
him a hall of famer based on his time in
minnesota so that that that
effort by peterson to run into the teeth
of the vikings defense and gain yardage
that's going to go a long way toward
determining i don't want to say the
outcome of the game but whether or not
they can hold the vikings under 30
points because just like we have said
with other great offenses this year
chris the best way to stop them from
scoring is to stop them from entering
the field so control the clock long
drives adrian peterson bang bang bang
that's going to be the match up if if
peterson can get his yardage and
washington can stay on the field
offensively maybe you create a greater
sense of urgency of the vikings offense
maybe you take a little steam out of
their attack and maybe you make it
easier to have a chance to at least
cover the 16 point spread if not pull an
upset well yeah i mean i hear you i
think that would be the formula now this
vikings run defense is pretty real we
know that uh but but yes to your point
that would be the game plan if i was the
washington redskins and then within that
you know if they got a healthy terry
mclaren and he's starting to get some
one-on-one matchups you know he's he's
gonna beat some people and what we've
seen is uh when he is healthy and out
there he is the go-to go-to guy for the
redskins offense i mean mclaren has been
one of the surprises of the nfl so yeah
you can go adrian peterson it can open
up some other opportunities and and
certainly like you said uh help out
their team in general the redskins
offense has been really the biggest
issue on that team this year all right
i'm going up to buffalo okay i'm going
up to buffalo because there's a coaching
match up there that's i mean big time
it's doug peterson versus sean mcdermott
and it's yes as head coaches but one's
the
de facto offensive coordinator the other
ones the defensive coordinator and
philadelphia it's it's do or die i mean
they're in trouble i don't like what i
see from philadelphia i don't think
they're going to be able to kind of
relish the season from what i've seen
the last few weeks on film and things
like that and i say this particular
match up because sean mcdermott is one
of the best defensive minds in the sport
and when you're a little too predictable
or have too many tendencies uh that that
you can you know lean on in a match up
mcdermott is phenomenal at getting all
over those tendencies and i see that too
much with the philadelphia eagles right
now you know there's no really uh what
do i want to say you know there's no
identity to their offense
if i was gonna say there's an identity
it's the kings of the five and ten yard
completion that's all they got going for
them but doug peterson's gonna have to
invent and come up with some game plan
specific plays if they want to beat
buffalo up in buffalo this week because
they certainly can lose this game we
know that buffalo defense is real the
eagles defen the eagles defense is
reeling and i think josh allen on them
will be able to make some plays on that
side of the ball so doug peterson is
going to have to have one of his best
play calling efforts of the year and
game plans if they want to win the game
i didn't want to interrupt you because
you were on a roll but at one point you
said if the eagles are going to relish
the season did you mean to say salvage
this year yeah yes definitely yes yes
they're not relishing the season right
now but yes i meant to say salvage yes
yes i did thank you usually usually the
word that you use
is at least in the same viral vicinity
yes that one was not at all
here's here's what's sad i knew exactly
what you meant thank you even though you
said relish thank you all right
all right
i i i've got i've got a couple more i
can choose from but i'm going to go
jameis winston versus jameis winston
clark kent versus superman can jameis
winston stay within himself listen to
his coach take coaching two weeks
removed from that debacle against the
panthers in london and emerge with a
victory in tennessee it's jameis winston
against himself that's one of the key
match-ups this weekend well i that's
certainly certainly a real thing i mean
he's jekyll and hyde i mean one you know
we see a few weeks of greatness and then
yeah we saw in london it was a total
disaster uh so he has shown some
progress this year uh but he took a step
back in that last game over in oakland
he's he's certainly got to continue to
battle those demons so i'm not going to
argue there it's kind of like a cheap
one jameis winston versus jameis winston
i mean get that
here i mean just yeah we're running out
of time you're going to pick a tie in
your power rankings again geez my my
pick okay and you missed this one to
start the real match up is
like bill belichick and the patriots
secondary versus odell beckham jr i got
to go back to that because i just want
to talk about that specific matchup
that's what i'm most excited to see more
than anything what is he going to do to
stop odell beckham jr is it going to be
stefan gilmore are they going to have
the guts to let him ride you know ride
or die man to man uh on odell beckham jr
or is it gonna be one of those where
they put two guys in odell and then
gilmore will co-cover jarvis landry i
just think that's one of the interesting
things i'm looking at belichick famous
for taking away the number one thing the
number one thing on cleveland's offense
is o'dell and i just want to see the
formula in which uh belichick picks i
won the draft what a shocker you
you jam one of your other favorite
players into the draft
it doesn't matter who's covering him if
baker mayfield doesn't know what's going
on up front okay james winston versus
james winston what a match of that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports